when we get back to luna they're gonna
kill me aren't they
if you're lucky yeah un still has the
death penalty on the books but they
don't use it much
i figure you'll be living in a tiny cell
for the rest of your life if it was me
i'd prefer a bullet how long until we
get there about five weeks
they were silent for a moment i'll miss
this place she said
amos shrugged actuator arm huh worth
checking you want to help me take a look
i can't she said gesturing at the clamp
on her leg
[ __ ] i can reprogram that least enough
to get you down to the machine shop
we'll grab you a tool belt peaches let's
crack that thing open
an hour later she was running her hand
over the frame of the door
looking for the telltale scrape of
binding sites
this was me she thought i broke it what
you think peaches
amos asked from behind her feels good to
fix something she said
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about amos burton and clarissa mal
two characters that have very different
backgrounds but come together to form a
really interesting bond i'll be talking
about how that happened
how the seeds were planted their
backgrounds and why they work so well
together
this video will contain spoilers if you
haven't watched the expanse through
season 5
episode 8 then you'll need to go do that
to get caught up first
i will be talking about some things i
picked up from the books without giving
away future spoilers from them
but we'll also be including some details
from amos's past that you would only
know if you read the expanse novella the
churn with that out of the way let's get
to it
right up front let me tell you that what
draws me to these two characters
is that they're both killers they were
both facing what amounts to a life
sentence
and then both got a chance at a
different life killing of course is
extreme and i'm not condoning it
not saying i'd like to be a killer or
that anyone else should be thinking
about becoming one
but i do think this idea of having a
chance to become someone else is
fascinating i think there's something
universal there
at some point you feel unsatisfied with
your life becoming someone else sounds
pretty good but if you weren't you who
would you be
it's like literally all you know and
what if who you were
was a bad person and you're not sure you
could be better so even if you're stuck
in a terrible situation
the unknown can still be frightening by
the time amos comes to visit peaches in
the pit he's already had some time and
distance between his rough beginnings
which we'll come back to in a bit
he seems compelled to want to go see her
but doesn't really have a plan
and there's not really much he can do to
improve her situation
he tells her people like us the things
we do
it's not just on us this world is messed
up and it can mess you up
he says he's lucky that he got out of
his situation because lydia helped him
and when she asked if he's there to help
her he says he guesses he is
and things take a turn when the rocks
hit not only does this effectively void
clarissa's sentence
at least as far as it destroyed the
prison where she's being held
it also provides a situation where amos
can more naturally utilize his skills
they're in survival mode and then so how
did we end up here
you might be wondering why when amos
went back to earth in season 5 he wanted
to go visit clarissa in the first place
it's been a while since i read nemesis
games for the first time but it was kind
of a surprise that he wanted to see her
as i remember it
in the third book abaddon's gate she is
a point of view character
as melba cole so we do learn more about
her story in that but it also feels like
her story is concluded when she has that
change of heart at the end and helps
save the day
if you've only watched the tv show you
probably remember that the first time
these two characters met
amos wanted to kill her he was convinced
that this was the right
course of action when anna intervened he
let go of the idea but he tells her
this one won't be grateful for your
mercy amos knows about killers
clarissa tried to kill his crew and
really that's all amos needs to know a
thing that stands out when you go back
and re-watch
is that anna tells him not killing her
isn't about her
it's about us amos doesn't respond to
that but we do see the wheels spinning
around in his head
as he thinks about what she said in the
timeline of events the rossi returns to
luna
turns her over to the authorities and
then eventually leaves for illis at
abasarala's request
on the way there the show added this
video call in the first episode of
season four
clarissa is now serving her sentence at
the pit and amos is the only person she
can think to call
now that she has that option available
to her she thanks them for the time they
spent together and she brings up a
question she had
at some point in the trip amos sent her
by herself to work on the seals of the
airlocks and while she was there she
realized that controls were overridden
and that she would have been able to
space herself after the fact she
realized that amos was offering her a
way to get out of this life sentence
and he confirms that saying that he
would want a choice if he was in that
situation
so where he started out telling anna
that it was a mistake to show clarissa
mercy
in that time they spent together in his
own way he was trying to show her mercy
by the end
the seeds were planted there so who are
these characters well clarissa mal
was the daughter of jules pierre mao and
the thing about her is her backstory
isn't nearly as harsh or harrowing as
amos's she grew up super rich and at
least materially speaking
she had access to anything a person
could want her dad is a prick though
without a doubt jules pierre is a bad
person
we saw what his legacy actually was and
on top of that he
is also a particularly bad father
clarissa tries to be the good child
she's desperate for her father's
approval and does what she can to keep
things together
in the family without much recognition
or support her sister julie does the
exact opposite and she's their father's
favorite
despite rebelling against him and the
rest of the family
and that's all sort of boo hoo poor rich
person a privilege finding out what it's
like when you lose a little bit of
status
and she did lose her father but he got
what he deserved
overall you can't really feel too bad
for her based on what she decides to do
and you're not really supposed to she's
introduced pretty clearly as an
antagonist
i think what makes the character work
though is there's some complexity there
that drive to get the approval from her
father that she'll never be able to get
there's just no way that it'll ever
happen
and how that unattainable goal poisons
things in such a way to foster a series
of bad ideas that bear consequences
all around when her father gets locked
up she makes one final attempt to earn
his approval
she goes to great lengths taking on a
fake identity
getting an endocrine enhancement implant
or a mod which we'll talk about a bit
more
and basically throwing away what life
she has left to go after james holden
james [ __ ] holden who took her father
and his legacy away from her and she
doesn't just want to take him out
she actually worries that he'll be
remembered as a martyr if she just kills
him so she wants to ruin his name
make sure he has no legacy left behind
and yeah she wants to kill him not for
everyone a tidy little redemption that
leads to that trip back to luna on the
rosinante where amos gives her the
nickname peaches
if you're wondering where that comes
from it's never actually explained but
the popular theory
is that since she went by the name melba
amos calls her peaches because there's a
dessert called peach melba
for as long as i've been around the
expanse subreddit someone comes up with
this
every so often and the obligatory
comment is
it's better than calling her toast she
does get a life sentence and because of
her mods she has to serve it underground
at the pit it's pretty harsh
but a lot of people died as a result of
her actions her ideas about holden
her father and who she is or wants to be
are all shattered
she takes responsibility somewhat sadly
isn't sure
she deserves any kind of redemption but
also
doesn't believe she's irredeemably evil
this comes out in the poem she wrote in
prison which says
i have killed but i'm not a killer
because a killer is a monster
and monsters aren't afraid peaches is a
killer she escaped a life sentence
and then she got a chance at a different
life
so what about amos considering that he
is a member of the rossi crew
and has been in the thick of things
throughout the series his story is a lot
more complicated
on the one hand we know a lot more about
him but on the other the fact that he
didn't talk about his past
made him an enigma and the fact that he
wears an
amiable smile and doesn't shy away from
violence really makes you wonder
there's a lot going on there at one
point he told alex
that he hasn't felt fear since he was
five years old he appears to lack
empathy or at least has trouble
connecting with people emotionally
he doesn't trust his own moral compass
so he looks to other characters like
naomi and holden
tries to think of what they might do in
a situation and then follows that lead
this has led to a lot of speculation
over the years about what was actually
going on with him
and it's not until he goes back to earth
that we get a better understanding of
just how traumatic his childhood was
and the kind of effect that had on him
his mother who died while he was young
was a sex worker under the control of a
local baltimore gang
his real name was timmy and he was born
into a life of
abuse and exploitation he was forced
into child prostitution at a very early
age
until he grew older and then lost value
for the people who were exploiting him
from there he moved into providing
muscle for the gang
and it's in that period of his life
where we meet him in the story the churn
after his mother died one of her friends
that was also a sex worker looked out
for timmy and tried to take care of him
at one point he's given the job to kill
his childhood friend
eric because of some trouble they got
into together essentially there was
evidence left behind a computer that
could be tied to eric
so his boss the real amos burton told
him to take care of the problem
he's ready to do it and when he tells
lydia about it she looks at the
situation
and realizes that she'll probably lose
amos
if he doesn't follow through with the
job because of how it played out he
would basically have to run away and
hide
at the same time she knows that if he
does it it will mess him up more than he
already
is and this is the nature of amos's life
sentence
because of his upbringing because of his
situation
he was always going to be stuck in this
life of crime where he would probably
end up dying
or being incarcerated lydia gave him a
chance
and this is where she delivers that line
that we saw at the end of the second
episode of season five
she tells him she loves him but she's
not righteous she can't teach him to be
that
but they can pretend to be if they want
and that's almost the same as if it were
true
this is where that idea comes from that
there are ways you can live a good life
without being a good person
in the end he decides to kill his boss
rather than killing eric
that means he has to leave earth leaving
lydia for good to keep her safe from any
backlash and he uses a fake identity
that eric had made up for their boss
and that's how he became amos burton the
documents got him into the
apprenticeship program he became a
mechanic
years later he ended up on the
canterbury where he met the
other members of the future crew of the
ross ante
and we know what happened after that
knowing his whole backstory we can see
how he became the kind of person he is
he had to be a survivor and he had to be
a killer to get out of baltimore in the
first place
the help that lydia gave him made him
want to try to live a good life even if
he couldn't be
a good person because he's a fan
favorite character
there have been a lot of great
discussions about amos's personality and
psychology
throughout the run of the series i think
one of the best descriptions i've read
came from a recent interview with wes
chatham the actor who actually plays him
talking to cbr he said so what he's went
through in his past
which has also kind of become a
superpower is that he doesn't have an
attachment to his ego or an attachment
to his identity in a certain way
so it allows him to do the math faster
than other people
and the reason that amos is able to let
go so easily
is because it was ripped away from him
at such an early age he's never had it
so in a way it gives him more clarity
because he can't connect because he
doesn't have the ego
the false self the identity that we all
crave
he's lost that and so it gives him
clarity but he also has a problem with
empathy
connecting in certain situations and
what i like about that
is that it is sort of a superpower we've
seen it time and time again in the story
where that ability allows him to thrive
in situations where other people might
not be able to come through
we also saw this on earth as they're
inside the prison as the rock hits
he's not afraid he's just figuring out
how to get out of that
the flip side of that is if he only
follows those instincts
then he really does worry about where
he'll end up he is a killer he escaped
his own sort of life sentence
and he got a chance at a different life
he understands this
and it's why amos and peaches work so
well together
one perfect example is their encounter
with the prepper at his compound
amos is in full survival mode and hears
about this guy they should probably
avoid because he's shooting at people
who come near his property
he realizes that this is the kind of guy
who's going to have what they need to
survive
and thinks that it's worth the risk that
he'll probably be able to figure out how
to take it from him when they get there
he goes there thinking they need that
stuff and killing to get it is just
something that will have to happen
it turns out that just has to use her
mods to save amos
they do end up getting what they need
but she makes the point that
it's not the kind of thing good people
do not even bad people trying to live
like good ones
you could pick up a lot from this scene
about how they're both broken in their
own ways and how they can help each
other move in the direction of being
someone else
she tells him the poem about not being a
monster because monsters aren't afraid
and this hits amos hard he doesn't feel
fear
and he worries that he might be a
monster when he thinks about her saying
that murder isn't something good people
do
he realizes that he needs to get back to
his crew the place he found when he got
away from earth the first time
and the home where he finds that moral
compass from his family
they are traumatized and in some ways
broken and they also happen to be quite
good at being killers
for clarissa part of that is that she
has these mods
and i said i would come back and talk
about them a little bit more basically
these implants were tested but they
weren't considered useful because there
was no way to prevent that
incapacitation that happens
after they use them so for military uses
say they could turn
soldiers into super killers for a short
period of time
but then they would have a bunch of them
laying around on the ground
recuperating they saturate the body with
a compound and enable the endocrine
system
to overproduce hormones and it creates
an extreme state of hyperphysical and
mental awareness which only lasts for a
short period of time
when you read her chapters in the book
it's almost like time slows down for her
and she's super powered
she can anticipate what her adversaries
might do and exploit their weaknesses
all while being able to move at
inhuman speed there's a lot of upsides
there but there's one big downside
in that they do degrade in your body
over time
she bought these on the black market
because like i said they're not popular
because of all the side effects
as the compounds leak into her
bloodstream it leads to terminal
illness she will die from it but she can
slow that down by filtering her blood
and that is most of what there is to
know about amos and peaches
their bond and time spent together has
always been one of my favorite parts of
the story
learning his backstory on his trip to
earth and seeing her struggle to leave
who she was behind to become a new
person
i really love the scene where she's
convincing eric that it's time to move
on from baltimore because the person he
used to be
there no longer exists she's able to cut
through his denial with an emotional
plea
because she knows what he's going
through she's able to be there
at that moment because amos was able to
be there for her
in a similar situation and it all goes
back to what lydia did for him
all those years ago and i will leave it
there let me know in the comments what
you think about these two characters
what do you think about amos what do you
think about his story
what do you think about clarissa and her
story
timmy and melba please like this video
if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon